Tina and Edward are with us on the line
from Cleveland Ohio hey guys what's up
hi we're doing good thanks for taking
our call sure how can I help my husband
Edward Edward and I are new to the Dave
Ramsey world and we are loving it last
month we put together our very first
budget and preparing to attack 195,000
of non mortgage consumer debt oh I'm out
shim by the end of the first month we
completed baby step 1
and we're working on baby step 2 at the
end of that first month we you know hit
put two thousand dollars towards the
debt bringing it to one ninety three and
we've adjusted our W fours
I recently can't we recently cancelled
my whole life insurance and are
currently holding on to twenty seven
thousand dollars until I finalize my
term life with stander we're also in
receipt of twenty thousand dollars in
the next two months or so due to a
medical settlement so our we're
currently working on getting out of my
car lease my question Dave is should we
drop the forty seven on debt or also get
rid of my husband's vehicle and use some
of the forty seven thousand to purchase
two used vehicles and then put remaining
on debt
my husband's thinking that we keep the
twenty five thousand dollar car in the
snowball and keep the vehicle till the
doors fall off
what's your not what's your household
income household annual income is one
hundred and fifty one 356 okay well the
rule of thumb that I use is pretty
simple usually um not nice yeah usually
over half the time that I talk to
someone in one of these conversations
the car is a blocker meaning
mathematically you're choking on them
and it moves the needle dramatically to
dump some cars
if you drive like no one else later you
can drive like no one else I mean all
you get is visualize and say my goodness
if we had no payments but a house
payment how fast could we save up and
buy some decent cars really fast so
we're not talking about driving
hoop DS or whatever for very long either
way whatever decision you make but even
if you don't make the decision or if you
do make the decision the rule of thumb I
use is two things number one you don't
want the total of all your vehicles
anything with a motor totaled up
shouldn't be more than half your annual
income you have not violated that
especially when you get rid of leased
car you're not violated that okay
because if you do you got if you had
eighty thousand nine thousand dollars
where the car is making 150 you got too
much stuff going the wrong way
it's going down in value that's the
point of that okay so the second rule is
can I be debt-free everything but my
house in about two years if not that is
the car the blocker and so I mean if you
had a two thousand dollar debt on the
car or a two thousand dollar car you
know the car is not your blocker then so
can you pay this off and keep the twenty
five thousand dollar car is you run your
calculations within two years I doubt it
okay because that's 100 grand a year and
you make 150 mm-hmm
to be debt-free in two years I mean it's
gonna be three years and yeah and so and
so the car does it you know the what is
it five six hundred bucks a month on
this thing does move the needle on that
seven grand a grand a year towards this
goal and again the thing you got to keep
in your head is it's not for that long
it's like two three years you're gonna
be buying another car that you're gonna
pay cash for probably as nice as this
one and you just pay cash for it after
you get your emergency fund in place and
what well you know what I forgot about
the forty seven thousand oh you can't
the cars I bought to know how far are
you upside down the twenty five thousand
no okay so let's just say if you threw
the forty seven straight at the debt can
you make it in two years that's what I
meant I forgot it because they instead
of one ninety five now I got 150 that's
seventy five a year out of 150 when you
that's laying it down hard I mean you
got no life doing that that's what but
that is what we tell people
to do is you know go crazy beans and
rice rice and beans
no like I think you keep it if you throw
the 47 at it and you commit to no life
MMH korch to earth on the lifestyle yes
lot of that Dave by my my hoot yeah you
got about 5,000 our car yeah okay yeah
well he gets Sunday federal law his wife
gets a good car he gets the hooptie I
really like them again it's just
temporary because you guys make really
good money you've just made really bad
decisions and now you've got a big hole
you're in but you got a good shovel and
you're committed you're on the call
together which says we're on the page
together we're both leaning into this
you know it's real good prognosis you
got all the symptoms of winning okay we
feel like we're winning already
suppose we got to talk to you yeah yeah
there's no magic there darlin but I
throw the 47 at it and lean into the
lifestyle in order to keep the car
because I think you can make it at right
at two years but that's gonna out of a
seventy-five a year that's what you got
to do out of out of a hundred and fifty
and that means you got after taxes
you really are not gonna have any room
there's nothing I mean nothing I mean
people are gonna be making fun of you
cause you're gonna be living on the
cheap but that's cool hey thanks for
calling in that's a fun discussion guys
sometimes y'all ought to do that the
rest of you some of y'all that call in
you ought to get your spouse on the
phone with you because you know I can
get my referee's whistle out and blow
the whistle and say he's out of bounds
right and that just solve it you don't
to go home and translate I can just talk
to him right here